for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
alright so we ended the last series on
the quantum mechanical model talking
about orbital energies in many electron
atoms and we asked how the orbitals are
filled with electrons that kind of
brings us here to electron
configurations so electron
configurations what do they do well
let's think about this question first
how does the distribution of electrons
and atomic orbitals of a specific
element relate to the chemical and
physical properties of that element well
before we mentioned that elements in the
same group have similar properties so
for instance the alkali metals in group
1a they have similar properties similar
reactivity alkaline earth metals in
group two similar idea they have similar
properties halogens they all have
similar properties this is due to
similarities in their electron
configurations which basically describe
what's going on as far as the
distribution of electrons in the atomic
orbitals of that element or that Adam so
moving forward with electron
configurations there are some things to
keep in mind the first thing is is the
number of orbitals the number of
orbitals in each sub shell if you recall
from the quantum mechanical model videos
we talked about how if you have an L
value of zero you have an s subshell if
you have one that were corresponds to
pee and I'll value of 2 corresponds to D
and I'll value 3 corresponds to F and so
the number of orbitals that you have in
the s subshell is one because there's
only one m7 value possible for an l
value equal to 0 for p if the l equals 1
you have three possible m cell values
and three orbitals so 3p orbitals and if
you have d the d subshell and I'll value
equal to two there are five possible M
sub L values which is
orbitals in the d subshell and 4f and
I'll value equal to three there are
seven possible M sub L values so there's
seven orbitals in that in the F sub
shell so it's also important to keep in
mind the maximum number of electrons
each of those sub shells have well if
that's the number of orbitals in each of
these sub shells each orbital can hold
two electrons so we chose a double these
numbers of orbitals to get the maximum
number of electrons in that sub shell so
the s subshell can have to the P sub
shell can have six D can have 10 and F
can have 14 so the way we're going to
represent that when we do electron
configurations is ns two and p6 snd 10
and f-14 ok that'll be the maximum
amount of electrons we can have in those
sub shells another thing we have to keep
in mind is that atoms are neutral why is
this well because the number of protons
equals the number of electrons and that
of course is going to be given by the
atomic number the atomic number is
defined as the number of protons in an
atom and if it's neutral deposit the
amount of positive charge equals the
amount of negative charge so the number
of protons equals number of electrons
the last thing we'll have to keep in
mind is how orbitals are actually filled
with electrons and that's going to be in
the next video we're going to talk about
that and the Alpha principle so I hope
that video is helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying